hey guys it's Justine and I am so
excited because I'm working on a series
of three videos they are going to be
shot stereoscopically and we're using
the z cam which shoots 5.7 k this is
actually a 3d video and it's also 180 if
you happen to be watching without a
headset to get this whole project edited
we needed a really powerful PC something
it was powerful enough to run a VR
software and the Z cam software
specifically and I also selfishly
wanted a new powerful PC for gaming so
right here we have the Origin PC
millenium and what's really exciting
about this is it's running at limited
edition intel iodine processor and it
also comes in a crate which is something
that's very interesting to me because we
have to figure out how to open it so if
there is one thing that I do have is a
lot of will and a lot of knives bigger
knives
[Music]
I've never used a chainsaw before in my
life
let's open this thing up I feel like I
need some eye protection cuz this key
the key you're very dangerous somebody
went shopping the hardware store me the
hardware store did not have a fitting
room this stinks did I buy these boots
just for this no I actually bought it
from a Halloween costume last year
[Music]
squeaking so I gotta put this one first
we might we might have a problem because
if I can't figure out how to put on a
safety helmet I probably shouldn't use
the chainsaw theirs doesn't look like
mine by the time I get my safety gear on
gonna be some sort of disaster I don't
know I don't I don't I'm gonna I'm going
to throw this thing across this garage
[Music]
yeah exactly that's what I was doing
here's the directions we're following
them Oh hold the other oh boy
so okay so let's see if this is gonna
work because now it's really tight I
think I'm I'm on and now ready for the
unboxing
probably a very very bad idea
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
I've never had more fun in my entire
life than making this first cut
pardon me throwing knife mommy's got a
job to do
[Applause]
[Music]
we have a really big problem I really
enjoyed that I think I enjoyed it way
too much I could do this all day if
anybody needs anything caught up you
know where to find me let's let's open
her up this is way less mess than I
thought it was gonna make here she is
welcome home my precious child
I guess I could probably take off my
safe to here now since we didn't use our
throwing axes yet great time to use them
these are so sharp oh my god how do I
get it out of here I know that I'm
making this more difficult than it needs
to be did you do what did you do
[Music]
got some power cables here some more
accessories take that upstairs but now
let's do the unveiling great welcome
home we made it upstairs and obviously
there's a lot of sounds happening we've
got the air conditioning running we've
got my server over here but now we're
gonna have a new machine to add to the
mix so let's spin this around and the
first thing that you'll see right here
is it says this is not a lift point so
if you were to pick this up this
magically comes off this is where you
have all of your USB ports there's also
at HDMI and Ethernet so this is where
everything is secretly hidden we gotta
take out the packaging from inside of
here this is just magnetic this is my
dog stick hey Maddy come here do you
wanna stick Maddy come here see my hand
for you hmm weird why is he not moving I
don't know all right Maddy
let's take all this out
okay so now we're down on the floor here
with our new PC so this hasn't unlocked
of knife dead until poor I 999 hundred
KS special edition processor and this is
one of the best gaming desktop
processors from Intel with up to five
gigahertz all core turbo and 16 threads
of processing performance right out of
the box or shall I say crate we've got
the msi z 390 gaming edge AC motherboard
we have the 8 gig nvidia geforce r-tx 20
80 we have 32 gigs and ddr4 ram we have
a one terabyte western digital
solid-state drive and we also have a 12
terabyte mechanical hard drive so now
with all that being said let's set this
thing up I also ripped my pants we can't
imagine how that happened today there's
also some accessories in here that I
need an angled HDMI since you have to
plug this in and put the cords through
the top power cable time to boot this
thing up
[Music]
there are so many LED lights in this
thing this is absolutely beautiful take
a look at that hey if you turn the
lights off we'd be able to see it hey
Siri turn off all my lights
[Music]
I mean have you seen anything more
beautiful it's all booted up I have one
of the lg ultra wide monitors what
should i do should I go watch one of my
own YouTube videos okay well it looks
like everything is set up all of the
drivers are installing all of the
windows updates are happening as we
speak I plan on doing a bigger video
talking more about this computer my
experience I also want to redo this
whole desk setup with Alton the chroma
pink razor stuff that I have it's gonna
look amazing before we go back
downstairs to show you how I actually
took this out of the crate just enjoy
this beautiful machine in 3d VR spoiler
alert it actually is a chainsaw while
the computers inside of it because that
is absolutely not the proper way to do
this so I'm going to open this the
proper way and show you what I did
before I destroy the box caution please
follow the instructions below to safely
unpack your system
as a side note always be careful with
power tools and do not try to open up
your Origin PC create with the chainsaw
and if you do make sure the computer is
not in it all boxed up ready to destroy
thank you guys so much for watching this
video this was so much fun and a huge
thank you to Origen for sending me this
new machine and I hope you guys enjoyed
this video look for a full set up tour
and overview of this computer and where
my new setup is so with that I'll see
you guys later